With over 95 million inhabitants, Egypt is
the biggest country in the Arab world.
And yes, I know what you are thinking, aren’t
Indonesia and Pakistan bigger than Egypt?
Aren’t they Muslim too?
Yes, my dear viewers… but make no mistake.
There is a difference between Arab and Muslim.
Islam is simply a religion while Arabic is
a culture, a race and, especially, a language.
And, inside this Arab world, Egypt isn’t
only the most populous country--it’s one
of the most influential.
This is why the Arab League has its headquarters
on the TAHRIR square, in the very centre of
CAIRO.
And why news like this is so worrying.
Death toll in Egypt rises to 305 people in
their deadliest terrorist attack.
Nonetheless, despite the latest news, Egypt
is changing faster than we might think.
Do you remember the Arab spring?
In 2011, thousands of people protested for
days to overthrow HOSNI MUBARAK, the dictator
who ruled the country back then.
A year later, the Muslim Brotherhood gained
power, ready to turn the country of the pyramids
into an Islamist Republic.
But now, in 2017, Egyptian politics are taking
a 180 degree shift.
Egyptian government closes 27,000 mosques
in move to fight terrorism
So now the question is…
How did we get here?
Is Egypt becoming a secular country?
Today we are going to answer these questions
but before we do, let’s take a look back
at history.
THE MUSLIM BROTHERHOOD
There are three names who define Egypt’s
history in the last 60 years: Nasser, Sadat
and Mubarak.
These three politicians have a common ingredient:
they were all dictators that followed the
principles of arab socialism.
This was the trendy ideology back then.
A cocktail that combined a centralized economy,
authoritarian leadership and secularism.
But… make no mistake.
As Socialist as they claimed to be, none of
those leaders had any problem with changing
their RUBLES into DOLLARS as soon as the Soviet
Union disappeared.
In fact, Sadat recognized the State of Israel
and, during the 80s, Egypt was already an
ally of America.
And, as you know, befriending America in this
part of the World puts you on the radical
islamists bullseye.
This is why Mubarak prosecuted every Islamic
movement.
Part of this repression was to avoid the terrorist
attacks that became pretty frequent in the
90s.
But Mubarak had other motivations too.
He wanted to stop any potential challenge
to his authoritarian rule.
And, guess who was the only organized group
who could replace him?
Exactly!
The Muslim Brotherhood!
Despite being a clandestine movement since
1954, the Muslim brotherhood is the most organized
grass-root organization since Egypt’s independence.
They have thousands of members and millions
of sympathizers.
Their goal is to turn Egypt into an Islamic
Republic, compliant with Sharia Law and the
principles of the Koran.
Nonetheless, the muslim brotherhood isn’t
the only radical group in this country.
Here we can also find the SALAFISTS, who pursue
the same goals by different means.
Look, the guys you see on the screen are Muslim
brothers.
As you can see, they dress in a very Western
fashion, right?
Jeans, T-shirts, hoodies, etc…
Now, these other guys are salafist members.
Do you see the difference?
Salafis have traditional muslim clothes, beards,
and the ZEBIBAH on their foreheads created
after hitting the ground so many times while
praying to MECCA.
As you can figure out by their name, the SALAFISTS
want to live like the first Muslims, the so-called
SALAF, did.
However, the Muslim Brothers are way more
pragmatic and better organized.
Their members infiltrate Government institutions.
And they have no problem disguising their
intentions when they speak to the Western
media.
We are not terrorists.
The Muslim Brotherhood’s philosophy is inspired
by an understanding of Islam that emphasizes
the values of social justice, equality and
the rule of law.
–Gehad el-Haddad, spokesperson from the
Muslim Brotherhood
In other words… both the salafists and the
muslim Brotherhood have the same goals, but
different strategies.
Today, the salafists have a political party
called AL-NOUR that has nothing to do with
the Muslim Brothers.
And, as you can imagine, the radicals don’t
like each other very much.
Remember this because we will go back to it
later on.
Anyway, during the 80s, the military dictatorship
of HOSNI MUBARAK attacked both of these groups.
In fact, since the year 1981, Egypt has been
in a neverending State of Emergency where
every political dissident is sent to jail.
This means thousands of salafists and muslim
brothers spending decades between bars.
As you can imagine, neither the European Union,
nor the United States did anything to stop
this.
At the end of the day, nobody wanted to see
the Islamic radicals in the Government.
If this was not enough, after the YOM KIPPUR
war, Egypt had become a good ally of Israel.
And their economy was on fire.
Think about it… this country has all the
ingredients for a World class tourism industry:
the pyramids, the Nile, the desert and the
red sea…
You can say that, by the year 2000, you couldn’t
label yourself a traveler if you didn’t
have an Egyptian stamp on your passport.
So, for 30 years, Mubarak had a free pass
to rule Egypt.
But… hold on just a second because, in 2011,
things changed!
Mubarak signals Egypt succession by taking
son to washington
News like this one made both the citizens
and some factions of the army equally enraged.
Having a dictator is one thing.
Having a hereditary dynasty of power is another.
This is how the Arab spring came to Egypt
and Mubarak had to resign.
A year later, parliamentary and presidential
elections were held.
We are talking about a country that has spent
decades under a dictatorship.
A country where the only strong political
movements, other than the Government itself,
were the salafists and the Muslim brotherhood.
So…
Guess who won those elections!
Exactly!
The Muslim Brothers, led by this guy you see
on the screen, MUHAMMAD MORSI.
But wait a minute because things are way more
complex!
Unless you are Saudi Arabia and you are sitting
on a pile of oil, Radical Islamism isn’t
good for managing an economy.
So, in less than one year, Egypt’s economy
sank.
Thousands of people lost their jobs and inflation
skyrocketed.
Meanwhile, Morsi’s main goal was to Islamize
the Government, stop the division of powers
and shield his power.
Add to this the army.
As we said before, Egyptian defense forces
are no big fan of Islamist groups.
And this is how a new player came into the
picture.
Marshal ABDEL FATTAH EL-SISI was the head
of the Egyptian armed forces.
He met the leaders of all the opposing parties,
including the salafists, and said…
‘Look, Morsi and his friends are fucking
up the government… help me set up a coup
d’etat and we’ll put things back in order’
And… as we say here at VisualPolitik…
said and done.
LAND OF THE PHARAOHS
By the year 2013, the Egyptian army kicked
Morsi out of the government.
Their first policy was to make the Muslim
Brotherhood an illegal organization again.
Of course, protesters went to the streets,
hundreds of them died and thousands were sent
to jail.
But in june, 2014, new “elections” were
held.
And I say “elections” because there was,
virtually, a single candidate: EL-SISI, who
had 97% of the vote.
The other accepted candidate was a guy with
0 chance of winning called HABDEEM SABAHI.
He got the other 3% of the vote.
Do you remember that scene in ‘THE DARK
KNIGHT’ with the line ‘You either die
a hero, or live long enough to see yourself
become the villain?’
Well… this could have been coined by EL-SISI
himself.
In fact, in the past few years, Egypt has
become the World’s leader in the number
of people given the death penalty.
But not only that!
In just 3 years, the Government has closed
over 27,000 mosques.
And there is no freedom of speech whatsoever.
And yes, I know what you are thinking!
The Islamic fanatics are pretty angry about
this, right?
Well, the opposite is true.
Do you remember I said the Salafists and the
Muslim Brothers aren’t good friends?
I was not kidding.
Egypt's ultraconservative islamists back SISI,
seek to eclipse Brotherhood
But wait a minute because things are not good
for the salafists either!
Of course, EL-SISI gave them enough freedom
so they could fill the roles left by the Muslim
Brothers.
But those Egyptian believers who want to go
to a Mosque have to go to those controlled
by the EL-AZHAR imamate which is under Government
control.
But you know what’s the biggest problem
here?
There are less and less believers in Egypt!
The percentage of youngsters who pray daily
has halved in less than 5 years.
According to the Arab barometer, in the year
2011, 84% of the population supported SHARIA
law influencing politics.
In 2016, that percentage fell to 34%.
But not only that!
El-SISI himself celebrates the Christian Christmas
in the COPTIC cathedral of CAIRO year after
year.
In other words…
Egyptian society is becoming more and more
secular.
But… before you get too excited…
Wait a minute!
This could change at any moment!
First of all, EL-SISI’s popularity fell
in 2017.
A good share of Egyptians do not like the
fact that he gave Saudi Arabia sovereignity
over two islands in the Red Sea.
They don’t like the repression either.
In fact, news like this one resemble Mubarak’s
times.
Egypt declares state of emergency after deadly
church attacks
On the other hand, the economy is Egyptians’
main worry.
Despite the unemployment rate going down,
it is still over 12%.
And these are the official figures.
Some experts say it might be over 20%.
And, despite all of this, the Government is
working on these pharaoh-like projects.
Egypt to build new capital paid for by China
Add to this the terrorist attacks and we can
only conclude that EL-SISI’s government
is failing more than succeeding.
So now the question is…
Do you believe Egypt can turn into a secular
country, the way neighbouring TUNISIA did?
Or do you think EL-SISI’s government is
DÉJÀ VU of MUBARAK’S and that, eventually,
we will see a brand new Arab Spring in this
country?
Please, leave your answer in the comment section
below.
And if you want to know what happened in TUNISIA,
do click on this other video.
And, of course, visit RECONSIDER MEDIA.COM,
the podcast that provided the vocals in this
video that are not mine.
Also, don’t forget that we publish brand
new videos EVERY SINGLE WEEK, so hit that
subscribe button to catch every post.
If you liked this video, give us a thumbs
up and, as always, I’ll see you next time.